thank you so much Dan for joining us on
the podcast today so Dan Lewis is the
CEO and founder of convoy were really
excited to have him here dan why I
wanted to start with your sort of
background primarily because now you're
building a trucking marketplace and so
was curious how did you know what did
you do and how did you arrive at this
idea yeah so it really comes back to a
combination of you know background in
supply chain and technology my family
run a mom-and-pop off supply company
distributing office pies all around the
Puget Sound in Washington and every
summer my job was to drive big Sprinter
vans to living delivering stuff so I
learned a lot about the idea of
warehouse operations and and delivering
but it wasn't really something that I
thought man I'm gonna go build a company
and do this you know I was pretty pretty
young and then after school ended up
doing a lot of work in transportation
and technology I work for the Panama
Canal for a while I ended up living in
Spain doing management consulting
thinking a lot about outsourcing of
maintenance and parts distribution did
similar work with some airlines and
companies in the knighted States and
then shifted over and started working in
tech actually my job in college was
building websites for the Yale athletics
department mm-hmm which was a great job
it was super flexible you know I got 10
bucks an hour and I could work in my
dorm room and but that kind of led to an
interesting technology and then after
you know after college and after doing
some consulting I was at Microsoft for a
while and a handful of other technology
startups and bigger technology companies
and so then I ended up at Amazon and one
of the things that I saw at Amazon that
kind of inspired me was I realized that
you know when I was growing up we used
to go to the store to buy stuff mm-hmm
and we would buy the same day that we
wanted it that was option value people
caught procrastinating it's I call it
option value you can decide the day you
want if you want to get it or not and
then online shopping came around and you
had to choose who I want to go to the
store and get it today
or do I want to buy it seven days in
advance and then it was five days and
then three days and then two and then
one and Amazon really took hold and
started
lower or you know raising the bar for
delivery and and and making it faster
and faster and all of a sudden with
Prime the decision between do I want it
you know really soon and do I want to
buy it online wasn't a conflict anymore
and Amazon really started taking over in
retail and it was really that that
caused me to think okay so the supply
chains winning it wasn't you know it's
not the location of the store it's not
the ambience how nice the sales staff is
how easy the parking is all that stuff
it's the fact that I can get it really
fast and that was driving massive shift
in behavior and we looked at a lot of
different companies out there I started
looking at so I was looking to a
start-up in general mm-hmm and I decided
to leave Amazon and go pursue this
looked and right when I was looking
transportation a lot of the companies
were last mile yeah so delivering you
know instacart or postmates sword or -
or uber uber rush or Google Shopping
Express all these different companies
that were doing that there were not a
lot of companies focusing on the middle
mile getting everything in the right
place so that you could do that same-day
delivery and that was the initial can I
was my background but kind of the
inspiration that led to thinking by
let's go build a logistics company and
one of the things I know like having
talked before is you actually worked on
even flushing the idea out a lot more
before you started building it can you
talk about that process in like you know
what what did what work did you do to
really understand okay this seems
interesting but is this real yeah and
when did you actually get convinced that
you are gonna go build this I was I was
liking what I was doing at mic job but I
had this you know I really want to go
start a company and and I have two kids
and you know my wife's at home with the
kids everything like that so I was like
okay if I'm gonna take this risk and
walk away for my job I better know what
I'm doing and so and I think because I
had done consulting I didn't really know
another way to do it I was like well I
have to go do a bunch of research mm-hm
and so I quit Amazon and I and I before
we decided what to build we spent weeks
full-time kind of out in the field
researching so what I initially did was
a bunch of online research to figure out
kind of what the general space looks
like and then I did three things in
parallel
I wrote to probably a hundred different
people maybe a third of them for my
background for young people I knew from
previous jobs it related to supply tune
that I could talk to about trucking 2/3
of them people I just found on LinkedIn
mm-hmm and just wrote to them or just
called them and all of them in trucking
in this way all of them in
transportation trucking could be you
know brokerages warehouses truck drivers
actually when my family on my mom's an
ESL teacher mm-hmm and growing up we
always hosted foreign students and
foreign families in our house and one of
them was from the Ukraine this guy's
name is Sasha he ended up running a
trucking business with his family and
his brothers out of Eastern Washington
so he was actually the first call that I
made and he was talking to me about how
he drove a truck delivering you know
produce from Washington to Florida and
and some other runs as well but I
started to do a bunch of phone calls and
then I went out in the field and I was
like oh I have to go talk to people
mm-hmm because that's the fastest way to
learn and to make sure I don't make a
big mistake and I remember it's kind of
funny I remember two things I wanted to
look professional
but I also wanted to fit in so I bought
a bunch of gift cards and I went to
truck stops and you know I wasn't quite
sure how to like engage people at first
someone sat in I went inside and looked
around and like went back and sat in my
car was like hey I got to think about
how I'm gonna do this and the easiest
person to go talk to is somebody who's
like filling the tires with air you know
so whenever I talk to that person and
then started having more and more
conversations at these truck stops and
learning more and more I didn't wanna
you know it was kind of like trying to
gather as much information as I could
did the same thing in warehouses just
walking you a bunch of warehouses got
kicked out of the whole foods warehouse
mm-hmm I think the door was not supposed
to be open I just walked in sort of
talking people in there like what are
you doing but over six or seven weeks
all that research in those phone calls
and people just want to talk to you
about they're doing you know so we
learned a lot of information we wrote
three or four business plans right I put
them together and then had a lot of
detail and tons of quotes and anecdotes
and real examples to back up kind of the
theory that you get from the data it's
online
and when we took that to investors that
was different and I had to realized how
unique that was until after I did it I
thought that was normal but then after I
did I realized not every you know
potential founder goes and does that
level of research before they start
proposing their idea and what were some
of the two or three big learnings from
you for you from that research in terms
of how you decided to launch Conway and
what pinpoints to solve yeah I think the
first thing I learned was one people in
the industry were super open and
interested in talking and interested
improving things so it was very
welcoming in that respect a quick aside
is that coming from a tech background
and you know and from a consulting
background I was always used to setting
appointments for links yeah I'm putting
something on the calendar and in
trucking you just pick up the phone and
call I remember so many times I tried I
set an appoint with something like no no
just just call me you know pick up so
that was different um but a couple the
probably the biggest insight we had
early almost trust there was a lack of
trust between parties in the industry
and you know people generally get along
but there wasn't like a deep-seated
trust that shippers were confident
brokers weren't taking advantage of them
you know in fact shippers often felt
like brokers and some of their
transportation parties weren't reliable
mm-hmm or they had issues or they they
you know didn't trust the pricing excuse
me and brokers also felt like you know
and they were working with trucking
companies that you know they didn't get
the respect they deserved for all the
work the trucking companies felt like
they were not necessary and truck
drivers would constantly tell me that
they felt like brokers weren't looking
out for them and that you know trucking
companies larger trucking companies
weren't looking out for these smaller
smaller guys and that they wanted
someone they could count on they wanted
someone who who would treat them fairly
and more transparently so there was kind
of a lack of data lack of transparency
and just that led to kind of some
mistrust between the parties mm-hmm and
honestly everybody you know the shippers
trying to get the best rate possible the
trucking companies trying to get the
best rate possible and the broker or the
3pl in the middle is trying to do the
same thing on both sides and so everyone
is trying to commit you know negotiate
all the time so it does breed a little
bit of mistrust so we realized you know
the first thing will
let's build a lot let's focus on
building trust let's focus on bringing
transparency consistency and visibility
into pricing and you know visibility
into where the trucks are which answers
a lot of questions
mm-hmm one of the one of the areas that
raised some lack of trust was that
shippers often didn't know where the
truck was hmm and trucking companies and
truck drivers wouldn't always honestly
report exactly where they were so there
was a trust issue on both sites
yeah not just on the driver but also the
shippers are all shippers yeah that's
right they weren't they didn't always
feel like they were getting a full
straight story and I think that's pretty
normal when you have you know big
industry and a lot of different parties
involved and and a lot of negotiating
involved every day and so all the
parties were kind of a little bit on a
love-hate relationship was now one of
them described it to me got it and how
does Conroy today you think solving that
trust issue on both sides I'll give a
couple of examples so when we have a job
for that we're gonna offer to the truck
drivers in our in our community and our
partners you know we figure out which
trucks that this or which carriers this
job is best for and we offer to them and
we show a price up front and that's a
guaranteed price and it's guarantee that
there's a real job behind that one of
the things that was common the industry
is that sometimes brokers and 3pls would
or even big trucking companies would
post jobs online there weren't actually
jobs they had yet they'd post them to
try to get a price yeah to figure out
what the truck would do it for and then
they can take that price and go back and
try to get the actual job we don't put
jobs up that aren't real jobs and that
was important and you know a guaranteed
upfront price we're not gonna go back
and ask you you know to pay you less
later and so there was price and
confidence and real job confidence and
we pay the drivers really quickly
they're also used to being stiff
sometimes and worried about not getting
paid and so we paid them very quickly so
they would have confidence the convoy
was actually you know respecting on the
other side with shippers we you know all
the trucks that run loads for convoy use
the common way out yeah and so that
provides real-time visibility for the
shipper to understand where the load is
and when the trucks arriving it provides
and actually a good another good example
there is if a truck shows up at a
facility
and it's delayed typically more than a
couple hours in the industry that truck
is gonna expect to get what's called
detention payment hmm for being delayed
now there's often debates around that
wouldn't you actually arrive you know
and the trucks that said they arrived
earlier in the ship and shippers would
say well they arrive later yes I want to
pay and so what we can do with that
real-time visibility is solve problems
like that we actually built something
that's pretty new in the industry it's
sort of automated to detention we just
track it and we pay the driver and they
can just do it right from the app mm-hmm
so they don't have to go through an
arduous process of trying to get that
that's great yeah so on the trucker side
you do it with guaranteed pricing up
front and a real job in quick pay was
this on the ship aside you're giving
them tracking info and even helping
solve for delayed shipments yeah that's
right in solving for just if you know
what it's actually there you can see
where it is you can get timestamps that
are real it answers a lot of the debates
that's great so let's go back to your
one of convoy because a lot of our
audience and actually early stage
startups and one of the big questions
they often have about a marketplace
because yours is a marketplace you have
truck drivers and shippers on the other
side so the first question you know most
of our viewers often have is how do you
bootstrap a marketplace and so how did
you guys go about doing it like what was
your one and convoy how did you find
your first few truck drivers in your
shippers we thought you know we went out
and did so much research that I had a
pretty good list of truck drivers and a
pretty good list of shippers right at
the beginning and so we thought okay
we'll go talk to a bunch of truck
drivers and get them signed up and then
we'll go to shippers and you know start
start bringing loads into this
marketplace and start developing it as a
broker and truck drivers weren't
interested to be honest we've gotten
talked to a bunch of them and they're
like well Joey loads yet he said no
nobody loads you don't know you know as
much as they loved the idea it's
vaporware for them it was like this new
company never heard of us before you
know and they also as I mentioned didn't
have a lot of trust mm-hm so they were
kind of skeptical of whose convoys
aren't going to download an app and
start using it they're busy and they're
looking for their next load right now
so we we said okay got it we're gonna
come back with some loads so then we
switched over went to shippers and we we
spent a lot of time again building trust
and and that's where we could sit down
with the companies that ship Freight
some early some of the customers you
know were print shops mm-hmm for example
you go talk to them and figure out you
know what is it you guys need where your
pain points they tell us they'd say okay
we can do this for you and so we're able
to get some shipments from them and
those because those loads don't have to
pick up for 24 you know 48 hours yeah
from the time they're offered to us we
had time to take that job and turn
around and go find a truck so we
actually used every single job as a
marketing opportunity and we used that
job to go find a truck offer them the
job they'd say yep want to do this work
for you we'd say great download the app
and it'll show up inside the app and it
was the it was the right kind of way to
get them to start engaging with us
mm-hmm through a real job and then to
get the job and complete it they would
have to use the app and that was fine
for them as long as it was a real job
that then started building some buzz
especially in the kind of the Western
Washington community where we got
started mm-hmm and then truck drivers
would tell their friends and we started
getting more on and we built some
referral programs early on once we had a
few truck drivers that trusted us and it
was you know pretty small initially but
a lot honestly it really came down to
getting the job and using that as a
marketing opportunity to get a truck to
sign up for the market yeah versus
trying to get supply before we actually
had any any action going yeah and most
marketplaces say that usually it's true
for them is the supply always goes to
where demand is so at least initially
and later yes so you know you did you
start off and Pacific Northwest is there
right because in Seattle yeah we started
off in the Pacific Northwest doing you
know straight truck work some long
struck deliveries around like Western
Washington mm-hmm as well as some full
truckload deliveries and honestly I
think we did up to about 150 miles when
first started so it was pretty tight
yeah and the idea was I mean trucking
you have you know you have local truck
drivers they typically don't run more
than 250 miles in one way because they
want to get home that night yeah
and as you know they don't have maybe a
bed and you know to sleep in their cab
and you have regional and long-haul so
we focused on the local folks initially
mm-hmm and the advantage there was that
when you're trying to build a
marketplace you're trying to build
density right you want to have a dense
number of suppliers and and invited so
because we focused just on jobs within a
couple hundred miles of Seattle every
truck driver that we signed up was
available the next day for another job
because they lived in that region and
they slept in that region every night
and so therefore we were able to get a
higher density of truck drivers quickly
in that region and start seeing the
marketplace take shape and start
learning how the business worked got it
so how many markets are you in today we
are just about nationwide now to be
honest you know parts of the the south
and southeast or where we're starting to
expand into now mm-hmm but we operated
out of all the major major metros right
now mm-hmm and you know we think of the
world kind of metro to Metro yes I think
about in terms of the shipping lanes
that exist got it so let me ask you this
because it's interesting it's always
interesting to see how marketplaces
scale it's very widely established that
you know uber and lyft vent city by City
right because they're the riders are
requesting for rights within the city
Airbnb was all about travels and one of
the things they did very early was you
know they went after all the high
tourist cities right New York London
rather than just doing us they just did
global cities that had a lot of tourist
traffic how do you guys think about
scaling so how did you decide you know
market number two after Pacific
Northwest or even from local to regional
like how what lens do you use to sort of
expand that's a great question so we
always thought about what's the minimum
viable footprint to serve our customers
and initially cut America that we we
serve both trucking companies and
shippers but initially the folks were
giving us jobs and loads that we could
take to go get truck drivers on the
platform our shippers and we had to
really understand what they needed
mm-hmm so initially as I mentioned we
focused just in the northwest and the we
thought about two different ways to
expand one was to take kind of the
initial services that we offer so the
types of trucking that we supported
which at that time were
was a drive-in you know Full Truckload
Drive an as well as flatbed and and
expanded into more geographies and more
lanes or instead staying the same
geography and add more types of drugs
and most of our customers that we had
today weren't we're much more interested
in us to expand to new geographies with
them then offering additional types of
trucks as most them we were already
servicing the types trucks that they
need and so we decided okay if that's
our customers that's what our customers
are looking for and that will help us
expand because will give us more Freight
and more volume and business as we
expand and so we essentially looked at
you know where did our existing
customers want to run fraid next and
those were that's how we started think
about expanding got it so sort of you
know what is the minimum viable
footprint for a customer where I can
feel like I'm really servicing them as a
partner and that's challenging and
Freight because I think you're right in
a lot of market places it's a specific
local geography and everybody stays in
that geography whereas in trucking one
company based in Seattle or based in
Portland might ship to a hundred other
cities mm-hmm
another company might ship to 90 cities
with 60 overlapping with that other one
right yeah so you kinda have to look and
see where you know what are the most
popular common freight lanes of your
customers and where do they want to
start shipping with you next and that's
a really kind of healthy way to start
expanding it to the geographies so
that's how we initially started yeah
going more broadly was through our
customers desire for us to service them
additional lanes got it when did you
first expand out of Pacific Northwest
how long were you in that 150 mile local
zone before you said hey I think we have
product market fit let's expand you know
I think we were probably operating in
that in that zone for for probably four
to five months which is quite normal
actually yeah yeah and then we so I mean
the exact progression which I'm happy to
share was Western Washington Washington
State mm-hmm
I remember drawing like the zones on the
map you know we're gonna allow shipments
to work and this is oh and like using
like a map in trend right cuz Washington
has some really remote areas yeah and
then we did Washington Oregon Idaho
and then we kind of did the i-5 corridor
going down to LA then we started doing
the western 78 so we really started to
expand in in the same contiguous area
then we went to Texas mm-hmm
and each of these different regions that
we went into we thought a lot about
different major highways and corridors
yeah and the in the major lanes where
were Freight runs and and that's really
the key is to understand sort of where
most of the volume is gonna be coming
and making sure you're building a lot of
supply there and it has been explained
ow that was the most challenging part of
this was our customers were constantly
asking us to go to new new areas and you
know for good reason they were excited
to work with us and they wanted what we
were offering in all of their
distribution centers around the country
for example and we had to be really
disciplined to push back and say no and
are in our sales team wanted to sell
more broadly because they saw
opportunities and our customers will be
saying look I can give you 50 loads a
week coming out of this you know this
city you don't support yet or this
region and we had to initially say no
and that was pretty unique for for us
most most brokerages would take Freight
in the lower 48 states wherever it's
available and try to mark it up you know
and make a profit whereas in our case we
were focusing on building density and
specific lanes and markets and so we
didn't actually go national we went kind
of laying by lay in Metro by Metro
initially and then since we've had a
bunch of national customers and so our
goal then shifted to okay as I'd
mentioned minimum viable footprint for a
market place to really service those
customers they they really needed us to
be in more geographies around the
country
otherwise we couldn't really have that
that partnership with them and then once
we want to service them around the
country well now we need truck drivers
around the country yeah so we start
working with truck drivers that run
nationally and then those truck drivers
are looking for their next load in
whatever city in the country they're in
so all of a sudden the footprint to
really serve that ecosystem expands
pretty quickly mm-hmm yeah and I think
that's been you know one of the growth
areas and challenges for us is figuring
out okay we have to expand it quickly
but still moderating in the sense that
we're not going to do everything for
everyone mm-hmm humans are infinitely
flexible so if we're it's
all if it's all manual it's all driven
by people that person can make it a
decision about which geography at what
price and they can call somebody and
figure it out we're trying to automate
it and run it through a technology
system you're trying to automate the the
transactions and the matching in the
marketplace you have to know the scope
mm-hmm it's really hard to train for
everything right so so that's why when
you're when you're doing this digital
freight matching in taking the perks
we're using you have to limit geography
where's a lot of other folks don't they
just go everywhere and that really is
indicative that they're probably not
using a lot of Technology and that's
probably not the most optimal because
you're not you know even though human
beings are really flexible there's only
so many permutations and combinations
they can do in their head yeah but a
system can do it way better especially
so if you learn over time ultimately you
can do a lot more now let's shift a
little bit to company building so how
was you know how big was convoy in year
one like team size year one by the end
of year one I think we're about 30 or 40
people Wow okay so we we coup relatively
quickly I don't think I mentioned to our
initial investors that I don't think we
had our bank account open we were trying
to take our first seed checks okay we uh
we had we had because we've done so much
research upfront we didn't worry
initially about incorporating mm-hmm or
getting the name set up we didn't we
didn't think about all those things we
simply just thought what is the right
business mm-hmm how do we get customer
data how do we understand what to go
build and then we had a great story that
we put together and we went to Radar
raise our seed around and it happened
relatively quickly how many people were
you in was it just you and grant the
co-founder or did he have more of a newa
raising the seed room yeah it was me and
grant and then it was five engineers
okay so you already had five engineers
yeah and they weren't full-time yet but
they were all committed to the project
and they were working on it kind of
part-time some of them were employed
elsewhere some of them weren't they were
working on getting it going mm-hmm and I
you know what I would think I learned
through that process was that I felt
like to me like angel investors and seed
investors look for three things the
first thing they want to they want to
see is that they can they believe in the
founders mm-hmm right they have a
conversation with you and they walk away
thinking I believe this person is going
to be capable of going and building
something
check box one right box two is the idea
seems reasonable for some investors for
seminal investors that means they
understand the space mm-hmm and they
don't invest in things they don't
understand for others it's they can
think through it and they ask them
around it and they feel compelled that
the idea could be reasonable and most
you know entrepreneurs that want to
start a new business can check those two
boxes you're going to come across as a
compelling individual because they're
passionate about this and they put a lot
of time to it and you know the idea is
maybe reasonable the space is reasonable
the hardest part is the in that angel
investors asking themselves can this
person go deliver on that vision quickly
and that usually comes down to do they
have the engineering talent available or
the specific skills available to them to
go build the company right away
and I had learned that over some over
time so one thing we thought was
critical from we're not too angel
investors was we wanted to have already
working with us a group of Engineers
that were willing to go and they'd
already said they want to start and I
found when I talked folks that was one
of the most compelling parts of it was
yeah they were excited about the idea in
us but then they said okay you know but
can you build it I'm not I mean I wasn't
gonna build the building on myself so
and my co-founder was a great ninja
engineer but again you need a team to do
some of this stuff and so that was
really the question was could we pull
the people together and already having a
few people working on it made it much
easier to raise the angel and where did
your first five hires come from was it
from your network or how did you and I
coop them yeah I was part of another
startup called wavy that Google had
purchased a few years back and a couple
of the folks had been part of that
company that start up in Seattle and had
been at Google for a while I think one
of them already moved back to Seattle
but they were interesting coming back to
Seattle and so those are two of the
engineers a couple of them were from
Amazon mm-hmm
had left actually Amazon a little bit
for around the time that I had we're
working on their own projects actually
we were we were I'm sitting at a table
working at my ko4 and I kind of had a
table we were working out and we invited
other friends and engineers in Seattle
that we're working on their own projects
come join us
mm-hmm and then as they were saying
next to us we were kind of like hey you
ought to help us with this little thing
we got him kind of excited about it
and we actually recruited two of the
people to help us just by inviting them
to come sit next to us you know to work
on their projects so those those are
both folks who've been in Amazon before
and then a fifth person I met through a
friend because also a previously at
Amazon so it was it was pretty tight and
I knew you know four of the people for
the engineers well before going into
this mm-hmm
and so by the end of the first year you
had 30 to 40 people right and how big
help you know what were sort of the how
much was engineering was the rest at
that point product and engineering was
probably 40 percent mm-hmm 40 percent
yeah God about 40 percent and the
company quickly shifted as we started
getting in tomorrow out of an
operational road mode we started
shifting more towards sales and
operations and you know customer success
and customer support and those roles
ended up growing faster than product
engineering mm-hmm it just
proportionally yeah all all is grown and
we you know we have a great product
engineering team we brought a lot of
great data science talent and recently
but but proportionally it's more sales
and marketing operations that's actually
common that I mean most people find it
counterintuitive but it's actually
common for most market places in the
early days where their ops team and this
you knows maybe the sales team start
scaling much faster than the engineering
team but there's obviously a point at
which you know you start turning that
dial
but for growth like it's pretty it was
true for Airbnb - it was true for uber
and lyft as well so it's actually quite
common so how big is the company now how
many people we are just over 200 people
now just over - and in less than three
years less than three years okay so one
of the faster scaling companies how has
your job shifted as a CEO from you know
you're one when you were managing 20 to
30 was as today like what what has been
the big changes you have had - yeah I
mean I think that my role is constantly
changing and I'm I'm always thinking
about that - because I I do worry that
all I won't like see a change that needs
to happen and do it well so I think when
I first started I was
you know I was visionary recruiter I was
out trying to convince customers
convince you know other employees to
join us
I had a diagram I drew I think I said
okay I need people with marketplace
experience and with transportation
experience and you know had a few
different dimensions to this was a
company go find those people so I was
pretty aggressive about going out and
trying to recruit and find the right
people for the company and and and then
we kind of got in then I switched my hat
we had maybe 15 you know 10 15 people
and I and I really switched to product
and kind of like business development so
then I was thinking okay what does he
one we were and convoy was found at
April 1st 2015 and we launched a
customer's at the end of August it was
very fast in terms of that run up and so
all summer you know it was a core group
of folks on cranking when building the
first version of the product so I really
shifted into like designer product
manager and thinking about kind of our
go-to-market for that initial launch we
usually call that the do it in chief
yeah it was the doer in chief for sure
and then we we announced and we launched
and then I shifted into fundraiser
mm-hmm
you know we went and we were like okay
now we have something that we feel like
it's working well it's out in the market
we've built a great view one we built a
good solid visual team let's go raise
our series a and so we went on and and
raised around from Greylock that fall so
the fall of 2015 and kind of closed it
right at the end of that year and that
was my first time having gone and done
around like that
yeah and so that you know to again it's
a different type of job and I'd to learn
how to be how to do that and how to
think about it from that perspective and
really think about what do we do next
and adding a little bit more structure
around the business and around the plans
and then I shifted back into like
salesman and chief mm-hmm or chief
salesman and I remember you know going
in and spending a lot of time with
customers over you know throughout 2016
on building relationships
Unilever had called us actually a really
forward-thinking shipper and they had
asked us you know if we were interested
participating in a pilot
that they were running with different
sort of digital freight companies and we
ended up becoming their partner out of
that and so I spent a lot of time
learning about their business spend time
with them and then spent time thinking
about who are other kind of similar
types of companies we can go and build
relationships with and that was really
where we started to expand more down the
west coast we started working with them
in Southern California and Texas and we
were looking for more businesses there
as well so that that year was really
again focusing on on initial sales and
it kind of kept evolving in there yeah a
couple other other hats you know we did
a lot of like really strategic business
development and early 2017 thinking
about ok now we have some real customers
how do we how do we get deep
partnerships right because if you want
to go accelerate and disrupted industry
it's great to have other you know
companies in that industry in that
business that want to support you doing
who and are gonna make an investment in
you doing that so that we've kind of
shifted our our and so I became more of
a strategy focused mm-hm strategy
business development focus in 2017 and
and I think my role will continue to
evolve as I step back and help the
leaders at convoy and you know working
become you know stronger bring in bring
in the right people develop people at
the company and really start building
the culture think about culture vision
and and sort of executive leadership
development is really where I think it
goes next yeah we actually say that role
changes from do it and chief to company
builder and chief so you know that means
you wear multiple hats at different
points in time so you know one of the
things I know you spend a lot of time on
is mission statement and building core
company values and really reinforcing
that within the company for culture so
talk a little bit about when did you
sort of define a mission statement did
you have it even before you started the
company or at what point and and also at
what stage of the company did you
actually list out the core values yeah
so our mission statement others say it
upfront is you know to transport the
world with endless capacity and zero
waste and we actually didn't codify that
that was sort of how we thought about it
we knew that 40% of the time trucks are
running empty there was an incredible
amount of waste by reducing waste we
could improve the economics improve
service you know everything gets better
it's a win-win-win so that was kind of
the vision
and we codified that just a month ago so
almost a little bit over two years in we
said let's write this down let's really
formalize around that what prompted you
to think about to codify this one month
ago alike yeah it's interesting there
kind of is that we were thinking about
how is our company growing there are
different sort of sizes of company where
the culture starts to change and you
need new mechanisms and and you need new
ways for people to kind of stay
connected and in touch and onion kind of
share information right so when we
passed 150 people which i think is
referred to as the Dunbar number because
it kind of refers to the number of
people that this this researcher
believed you could kind of have social
direct social interactions within
relationships with or direct
relationships with we felt like we
needed we wanted to kind of take some of
things that we all like talked about and
believed to make them more like
constructs of the business that
everybody knew coming in would learn
about and think about and then kind of
represent who we were as we started to
get bigger yeah and then to the values
so you know to be you know we have a set
of company values we use them all the
time we use them for every recruiting
and every time we interview somebody let
me put how did you guys come up with the
values yeah so I came from Amazon mm-hmm
and I've gone back to that a couple
times but but Amazon has a set of
leadership principles and that construct
we liked so we said okay it's an
interesting concept let's look at that
and actually I had a chance to chat with
so Jeff is one of our investors he had
talked about how they formed their
values which was I think was about a
year in or maybe a hundred people they
decided at that point they would codify
their beliefs and what they thought
worked mm-hmm and we we had had similar
ideas we'd actually kind of before we
even raised money right right around
that time me and the engineers I
mentioned and my co-founder had sat
around and said one of the values of the
company gonna be and we decided way too
early to decide yeah you know we wrote
down some things right we don't really
know we are yet we can't just say who
are gonna be let's be that and then
let's write it down and so it actually
came about a year into the company in
early 2016 we decide ok we're getting oh
but bigger we're about 30 40 people you
know at that point
and we wanted to have consistency as we
start to scale I woulda known OTT you
know new people were coming in to do
interviews we were trying to scale sort
of a little bit on management and review
process and things like that and and and
kind of remember who we were and so we
said okay what do we like about
ourselves what are the qualities that we
think one of them is know why that was
really important because if you don't
know why you CAC you can't act
independently you can't you also have to
go back and ask for the next step if you
don't all that context upfront or love
problems not solutions we saw too often
teams being named after the solution
like you know the could be the reviews
team or could be the search team where
the solution is that but the problem is
you know I need I need customer
confidence or I need to find something
so we always want to think about how do
we reorganize oh we don't forget the
original problem we were trying to solve
and fix it too much on the solution we
came up with and so we create these
values that kind of help steer some of
the way we think and then we thought
were really valuable that happened about
a year in and that was from an input
input from probably you know at least
half maybe maybe more of the company at
that point mm-hmm I'm thinking about
what this could be
and then over three months we kind of
wrote them down debated them I think we
all we sat in a Thai restaurant for like
four hours at the end and we're not
leaving till we're all we all agree that
like this is v1 you know god and we
wrote him down and it's a living
document and and it's something that you
know we've actually evolved we actually
just added a new value about a month ago
mm-hmm which is bring out the best in
others mm-hmm and and that's one that
kind of represents a lot about where the
culture is developing but it has been a
pretty core part of what we've done in
terms of trying to build a consistent
yeah
consistent values throughout the company
and how do you test for that in your
interviews like how do you make sure
that the next person walking into the
door is you know is the person that you
want both from not just from skillset
and competence but also from a cultural
fit yeah so we have on you know a pretty
thorough interview process both on you
know in person and we do some offline
stuff and we we actually upfront a sign
we assign people that are doing
interviews different values to learn
about and then we have different
questions you know they can make up
their own questions
we have you know banks of questions
we've thought of that kind of represent
those values is we actually make sure
that we ask and we make sure we were a
little bit comprehensive in terms of the
types of questions we ask to really
understand I you know if somebody if we
believe someone represents those values
often you know look with any interview
process it's gonna come down to
someone's personal opinion yeah well
that always it always weighs in
yeah but this is one way to think about
being consistent there and we almost
always have somebody from outside the
group that's part of every process as
well who's really looking at the values
and saying you know I'm not personally
gonna benefit you know this person
joining but I want to meet you know in
terms of my team but I I want to make
sure they're the right for the company
mm-hmm and does that person's input get
any higher importance or lower or is it
the same as the rest person who comes in
from outside yeah yeah that person
actually has to be bought in has to be
bought in so that's your test for the
got it okay and then now you're almost
at 200 people do you still interview
every candidate what point did you stop
and know what you know I'm sure you're
still interviewing quite a few of them
but how do you decide and how involved
do you get in the process yeah I'm no
longer interviewing everybody sadly I
really enjoyed that I talked to a lot of
our you know other entrepreneurs that
that I knew or order who'd invested in
in convoy about how they did that and I
thought one thing that was consistent
with a lot of the ones that seem to be
really successful was they had actually
interviewed for a long period of time as
many people as they could so I probably
stopped either bring everyone after
about 150 employees mm-hmm so you almost
interviewed everyone to 150 yeah I do it
but I would I would do a phone screen or
I do some sort of yeah you know
different level different stages the
interview but I would get involved and
and have a conversation and honestly it
wasn't so the thing that's important to
me was it wasn't just about me
evaluating that person it was that I
wanted them to evaluate me yeah because
we were joining an early-stage startup
the CEO has a pretty outsized impact on
your career and and the company you're
joining and I wanted them to come in
saying I believe in a company I believe
in the leader of this company you know
I'm not gonna be said I don't want them
to meet me three months later and
vip-only I'd met Dan before what I've
never joined so it was actually
important to me that they
that they had a chance to meet me and so
what I do still is with everybody that
joins convoys I do you know try to get a
one-on-one with them within a couple
months of them joining or sooner and
really just sit down and listen to how
they're thinking about it what they want
to do and we get to know each other a
little bit because it's important to me
that they have a chance to learn more
about me because they're making a bet
and I you know I'm honored and feel like
a lot of responsibility for the people
that decide to do in convoy now there
are many founders we see even at YC and
often one of the things they talk about
is hiding mistakes and you know it's
inevitable but are the things that you
went through at Conroy which were great
learnings that you think everybody
should have in their interview toolkit
yeah I think a couple things one is
trust your instincts it's all you know
it depends on you know the the type of
hire but almost every hire has
significant impact on a lot of people
and if a couple people in that interview
loop have instincts that where they feel
like something's wrong where there's
something off culturally or there's some
sort of that person there was some some
issue related to those things you really
need to trust that when we have ignored
that that that hasn't always results in
the right outcome or we had you know
maybe we didn't didn't listen as much in
certain times and this person seems just
right for all these other things you
know and so early on we learned a couple
things there the second is we have a
written component to almost all of our
interviews hmm and a lot of them we've
even done a little quantitative tests
and things like that because you can
learn we're trying to learn it but we're
speed-dating right we're trying to learn
a lot about each other quickly an
interview in person with someone is
going to show you one side of that
person but their ability to write and
structure their thoughts on paper or to
do an exercise is also going to show you
a lot more about them as well and so for
different types of roles thinking about
other exercises helps you learn much
more about that person in the same
amount of time and we found that you
know some people will be great at an
in-person discussion and not as great on
the other components or vice-versa and
we need to consider that
give an example of written exercises yes
so one of it one example would be we
might ask a couple of strategic
questions and and/or a one strategic
question one a very tactical question
and then ask the the person that's
interviewing to put together a written
response to them hmm and then we'll read
that written response and try to ask
them about it during the interview so
not only do we learn you how do they
write which is a incredibly important
skill for most jobs mm-hmm but also you
know how to be structure information how
thorough are they how seriously did they
take it
yeah I the I ask a couple questions
they're a little bit almost out of the
ordinary sometimes and I found that
those are really important for a startup
I'll even ask them to someone
interviewing for like a c-level position
and they I don't want to say it exactly
because I actually want to keep using it
we're not giving the committee yeah no
but it could be something that's totally
out of the ordinary it's like hey work
on this kind of exercise not expected
again guarantee they didn't think about
that coming in and I'm not I'm half
interested in the response mhm because
it teaches me I can learn a lot from
that yeah but I'm also interested in how
do they handle that question yeah do
they actually act a little bit are they
little entitled like yeah I don't think
I should answer that's a question why
would I have to answer that question
right so putting somebody in a position
where you're asking them to do something
that maybe they think is extra work or
is a little bit off topic from what they
expect the discussion about is a great
way to learn their attitude yeah let's
show it are they entitled are they not
you think those sorts of qualities you
really want to understand during an
interview process and now that you have
200 people and you're probably hiding a
large portion of your leadership team as
well how do you assess if someone can
scale to the next level or the next role
how do you sort of do that yeah that's I
think a extremely important question and
really challenging and I know something
that a lot of different CEOs that I
spoken with have challenges with here's
how I think about it the most important
indicator is hiring so if someone wants
to get to the next level and they're
saying well how do i how do I get to
next level this company how do i scale
with the company as the company gets
bigger yeah
I mean the thing I think about what I'll
say is well can you hire the person
that's doing your job right now that's
as good or better than you in that job
you know can you convince that person to
come join convoy and work for you mm-hmm
and if you can that's how you scale you
bring in the people that can help you
scale by by building a team that helps
you kind of step up to the next level if
you you know if you can't hire those
people if you can't recruit and attract
them and and they're not ready to work
for you then maybe that's an indication
that you're not at that next level yet
mm-hmm because you can't recruit the
person to work for you that would help
you get fixed or that is at that level
today interesting test yeah yeah and
I've found because often times what
you're really deciding is you know if
someone's in a certain level well are
you gonna hire that person's boss it's
if this let's say the company gets 10
times bigger and you have a much bigger
organization any more senior leaders
will do you hire the person's manager or
does that person step up into that role
and hire their replacement and you
certainly can't say you don't want to
lower but you want to say well because
you are a little more gene you can your
replacement can be even more maybe more
or less experienced than you yeah no no
that person has to be you have to pick
something that raises your bar you know
it's better than you can you hire that
person in if you can and they're excited
to come work work for you then that's
that's a path to the next level and
that's interesting because you know I've
heard two schools of debate on that
meaning some people think that anyone
who doesn't have the title of a CEO
makes it harder for them to attract any
candidates because you know people
outside perceive associate title with
sort of authority or decision-making
power and the other school of thought is
more like hey let's just you know put
them in that role and test them as to
whether they are able to scale because
if they are drowning in water you will
probably know that pretty quickly so
what's your sort of reaction especially
to the first argue first pushback which
I've heard which is like hey but you
know title some community to some extent
gives some level of authority and that
automatically allows some you know more
experienced candidates to talk to them
because if you look at it most CEOs
haven't you know especially CEOs of
startups haven't done any of the jobs of
the senior execs that they are hiring
for they've never been a CMO or a CFO or
a CRO yet they have to be really good
tracting candidates well 20 years of
experience being a CMO and one school of
thought that it really comes down to
okay who's the CEO and how compelling
the vision is yeah you know I whenever
i'm hiring somebody for a role like that
like a senior executive role and we're
talking to people right now half the job
is doing that is doing the job half the
job is building the company in the
culture right so and I think that that
is extremely important to me and that's
when you know when I think about
somebody coming and joining it whatever
title but sort of in that senior role
you know that's what a lot of people are
looking for like they they're they want
to join a start-up because they want to
help build something and they want to
develop something that doesn't exist
today and so I think that um other you
know leaders in the company can do the
same thing which is you're you're
bringing someone to help you build that
organization and it's really about
selling and telling the story that
you're empowering that hire to do
something bigger than they've been doing
they're gonna be excited about and that
you're not hiring them to fill a niche
and a slot on your team you're hiring
them to do your job in some ways so that
you can step up and do more mmm-hmm so
when I think about a leader on my team
hiring somebody if that person
approaches it is I'm gonna hire the
person and I want them to take over a
big part of my job I'm gonna give them
big for my job that's how it's really
hard to make that mental leap but doing
that that's really what the nice yes
yeah if you want to hire someone to fill
a slot that that secures your job then
you're probably not ready for that next
level yeah that's fair that's very good
assessment one last question is you know
one of the things another question we
get from a lot of our founders is as you
scale right from year one to year three
and now here are 200 people there is
some tension about you know what happens
to the team the first 20 or 30 employees
and there are there's usually tension as
you scale in terms of you know it's more
probably psychological than real but how
much influence do they still have in
decision-making across many areas which
they would have had in year one but now
obviously you have various leaders and
various functions how did you sort of
manage that like in terms of you know
especially when your company when the
company went from 30 people in year 1 to
200 now
and did you a see that tension from the
first 10 or 20 hires and if so how did
you sort of manage that to make sure I
want to make sure I understand correctly
you're saying you know really early
hires how do they evolve at the company
as it grows in scales yeah and I think
more is like how do you empower them to
feel they're still as involved in
critical in addition making versus them
fearing that you know they're now just
one silo in the company yeah that makes
sense and you know I think so first off
obviously people are going to go into
different roles over time and so I think
it's really with Winnett with within
whatever role that they are doing how do
they recognize that their job is to do
more than their job it's to represent
the company culture is to represent the
history of the companies represent the
mission of the company and that they
have the responsibility and also the
ability to do it based on being there
very early to really have the community
I should say the credibility to go do
that so one is just really positioning
it that way and talking to them and
about them and getting them involved in
a lot of things outside of their own day
job
yeah you know I think another one is
that one of the things that happens and
actually thing I learned this I'm trying
to remember I want to give credit go
crazy I first met you at the Etta YC and
guerrilla kind of growth event in San
Francisco and I believe I heard somebody
at that event I don't remember exactly
who talking about how one of the biggest
challenges as a company scales is at the
early employees feeling like the
company's less transparent mm-hmm right
that they're there's less information
flow to them and I think it's completely
true and it's not that there's
necessarily less transparency over all
it said they're just not gonna see as
much because they're not there so I
think again a big part of it is actually
creating a way to share more information
mm-hmm and that's part of the no y value
that we have a convoy which is people
really need to know why they're doing
something you've had that context and
and so we have actually we want to make
sure that people are involved in things
that go beyond their job and have more
visibility with the strategy of the
company
we share a lot of that with the whole
company every week and that I think
keeps it so that folks that are there
early feel like their visibility where
the company's going yeah and they can
make a lot of sense of it and they're
the ones that there are peers or other
people to come you're gonna grab and say
hey what is it what did they mean by
this room yeah what's this really mean
and they can help
explaining that and share that more
broadly across the company because they
have all that context in history to
really know where everything's coming
from so a big part of us just continuing
to share a lot and empowering them to
kind of be the champions of the company
beyond their their job that's what
that's what I found and obviously I
actually when I when I talk to a company
today I'll you and I still believe it's
100% true
I remember saying this at 50 100 hundred
etutor everyone in that room is going to
be that person for the next you know 200
next 500 people that are at convoy and
so it's important that they that they're
viewing their job not just about you
know completing the tasks of it but
understanding the mission and the
culture of the company so that they can
represent that and push that forward and
pass that for the next yeah so we
actually explicitly talked about that
our company means a lot but I think
that's it just has to be something
that's that's ground up it can't be like
top-down from me yeah awesome well thank
you so much then thanks for the time
you